first things first what do I call you
long blood
one young dumb just call me dr. blood
mr. blood yeah whatever you want
okay I'll stick with Dom that seemed
that affect fish bash bass there we go
so for those who haven't come across you
I mean just it trying some of you can I
mean who is Youngblood
where are you musically I am I am from
obvious I'm from the north of England
I'm 21 years old
and I kind of write songs about what's
going on in my head I write songs kind
of for for a generation right now that
that kind of feel quite misunderstood
you know I mean I kind of all my life I
kind of felt that and you know it's very
easy to say that you know I mean but I
genuinely did and I think man I think
music right now is kind of lacking truth
I just wanted to write write songs that
would obtain truth and still before and
still be upbeat and kinda just do my own
thing you know my generation right now
we are really intelligent I think that's
why I kind of as I say the x-factor its
kind of people seen through it a lot
more there's more often - yeah that's
what I'm saying because it's as I say
people have seen through this
manufactured manufactured music industry
you know I think like because everything
is on is on social media right now
people know what's real know what's not
we are so intelligent because we have
access to so much information that we we
become smart and we become smart very
young as like Oh as young as 13 you know
I mean like some guy when I speak to 13
year olds and my shirt that blows my
mind I'm like wow you know that I didn't
know about you taught me something new
you know so it's a good audiences in
musical terms perhaps a bit a bit
choosier than than they were in the past
yeah I think so I think to be honest as
I say like I write songs for a
generation that are so intelligent and
see a future we want to be a part of we
know a future we want to live in we know
what we want we almost kind of have this
this not arrogance put this confidence
in a world that we want to
but it's almost been held back by part
of a generation are blinded by like
cataracts of old ideologies that don't
want us to go to that place yet or
aren't quite ready for us yet all my
life I felt like I don't know I felt out
quite misunderstood because I had an
opinion all the time and a lot of people
suppress that opinion especially people
in power like my some teachers or kind
of older people I think for me and I
understand it now I understand it's hard
to be confronted by someone especially
if they're younger than you because
you're like hang on a second what do you
know yeah I'm afraid it uncomfortable ya
know so I'm gonna second what do you
know I'll just like if you give me a
chance I might actually surprise you I
might actually say something of worth
because I see the world in a way that
you might not and you see the world in a
way that I don't I'll I just want to
have a conversation about that and see
if I can change your mind or you might
change mine now let's see let's see if
we can spark a bit more conversation
yeah take a look at one of one of your
singles I mean this is the video for
psychotic kids yeah
[Music]
I'm not the best at analyzing music
videos but I'm detecting some imagery
there that may well be related to mental
health yeah absolutely man what were you
trying to see with that I was just
trying to say that with our views on the
world I get looked at like I'm mad or
I'm a psychopath if I want to put on a
dress or if I want to I want to abort
the kid that's gonna that's gonna ruin
my future or I want to kiss a boy or I
want to marry a boy do you think you do
get looked at differently these days if
you want a man what's you wear a dress
if I think as I say it's been chained
it's changing a lot now it's becoming so
much more accepted which is absolutely
amazing but what I grew up in kind of
five years ago it was it made me feel
small because I was having these stores
you know I mean I thought to myself like
I cannot tell anybody about this because
the society I grew up around seems so so
suppressing towards me I was frightened
you know I mean at the end of the day
what I want my music and what I want my
videos and what I want every single part
of you in would to to resonate is that
you can be yourself no matter what
because you are beautiful the way you
are I have felt like oh my god maybe
maybe I'm maybe I'm gay maybe I want to
kill myself
I have been to a party my head that I
got really scared to go to when I found
it because I didn't know and I didn't
I'd wake up in the morning the Sun would
be shining and then and and I'd have a
knot in my stomach and I couldn't quite
figure out why and the people that some
people are told about it would just like
oh man you'll be all right you'll be all
right you'll be all right and it's fine
and it's fine and maybe I wasn't all
right so now I'm pointing this in my
music to speak to anybody out there who
feels like that and say it's alright
because in this community you can be
accepted and I want you to have an
outlet to to say what you think and say
you feel man you know so I wonder then
those is making music like that is that
also is that also process of catharsis
for you is it a way of you dealing with
with your mentor no I mean I'm just
what's where it started that's where it
started it was like it was a release
about me going oh this is what I think
this is what I felt along the world I
need to get this out because I don't
know music is a way that blew my mind
that I could you know I mean music was
an outlet all the time when I'd listened
to like The Clash when it wasn't a
Manson when I'd listened to em when I
listened to Gaga when I listened to Joni
Mitchell when it you know I mean I hope
be kind of like these people could
express themselves and be themselves no
matter what so why can't I and any
initially it started with me getting it
out but when I first put out King
Charles I just wanted to put it out I
was like saying to me management I had
no record no I was like let's put it out
let's put it out in with my management
company my publishing company let's just
put it out and see what happens because
I want to start playing live and I was
like in a studio sitting on these
records like come on man let's just put
them out and they're like you're looking
for a response then from would you see
what happened I just wanted to see what
happened and see if like oh man this
might go well if not I've put a song and
Spotify at least my mum can be proud of
me sure I mean but the response
it started in Holland and Germany
initially and it became less and less
about me and more and more about us so
why do you think it's that the young
people's mental health these days is so
seemingly precarious I mean I read an
interview with you who you were talking
about receiving hundreds of DM yeah from
from the fans of euros and fancy music
in front of what you were saying talking
about it but why aren't young people
seemingly so so so conflicted about
their mental health given so much that's
improved over the last 50 years life
expectancy job a corner opposite I think
it's because we're growing up in a
millennial generation I'll touch on in a
second but it is that thing where it's
been accepted and I feel like I can talk
about it I feel like I have an outlet to
talk about because finally this
generation says
you can talk about how you feel you know
I mean people like go it's so hard to in
this day and age go I need a second just
to think I need a second just a thing
it's like why why do you need a second
just to think it's it's a generation
where it's not get on with it you're
gonna be fine have a cup of tea stiff
upper lip you can refine its if you
genuinely feel this way then talk about
it and it's amazing because the amount
at the ends I get and and the amount of
the the response to the music and the
people I talk to we genuinely we
genuinely feel we can talk about that's
why it's become such a not rising almost
because it's accepted I mean this is
something this is something you've
touched on before I just wanna read you
a bit from another interview he gave we
you referred to the Deaf upper lip
generation we can swear sorry man I did
wear honor I won't go too into it we
might we might apply the people yeah I'm
censoring myself
so our but it's this idea this idea that
you know that people have been to the
detriment of others same ginawa get over
it you'll pull yourself to get ya don't
you think that there are some
circumstances in which people you know
maybe do need I kick up the backside to
not dwell on something that's that's
that is undoubtedly negative and a side
a negative but I think that's very hard
because it can go two ways man with me I
always say try and find something
positive I don't say get together man
that's that's the wrong way of dealing
with it because fighting confrontation
in fighting an internal confrontation
with an external confrontation is only
going to cause more confrontation that's
just a formula that's never gonna change
it's the way you deal with it and
everyone's different man that's why rap
music because that takes away my
external confrontation or if I have an
anxiety attack in bed like I always have
a problem sleeping just cause at a
lifestyle that's going on right now and
etc and whatever and the pressure and
blah blah blah blah blah what works for
me is I write down one feeling because
it's a release without you know I mean
I'm just right out just be like
I am feeling I am NOT going to sleep
tonight because I have a massive gig
tomorrow that is gonna go wrong and my
voice isn't gonna be right and it's all
smile it goes out and actually go oh
well I feel a lot better I just wanna I
don't want to cut I don't want to tell
people what to think I don't want to
tell people you need to be better you
need to make sure that you get up
tomorrow and you have a good day I just
want to encourage people to say what
they think I don't people to be able to
go I am NOT okay and I'm gonna try and
work on myself to to make sure I can be
better you know I mean I think it is
that thing fine confrontation with
confrontation is only going to cause
more confrontation one of the ways in
which younger people seem to be
expressing themselves these days certain
certainly with greater volume than
before is through gender identity yeah
what is happening there in you of you
mean you know that direct line to young
people in a way in which I simply don't
I mean why are we seeing this explosion
of people questioning their gender
because I just think we feel like we can
the world is becoming so much more
liberal and it's so funny man it was
like you haven't argue when your parents
were in their generation it's like well
it's not normal I'm like sorry I'm like
what you mean it's not normal normal is
changing normal will always grow and
develop if we are allowed to express
ourselves and people feel like they
don't have to suppress oppress the
feeling there's a generation of people
were that might want to be bisexual or
might want to become a girl but they've
felt like they cannot do that and
they're living in in a body that's not
theirs but suppressing it because of the
way society told them that they could
live their lives now peep that there's
so much especially in my generation
words I am gonna be where I'm gonna be
if I think I'm a girl I'm a girl you
know I mean if that's that's that's the
way out that's the way I am and you
understand how weird that might seem to
people who ignore nice
you know when I say anything whatever
aggressive individual who said they're
good I just don't get I don't get and
that's what I'm saying like like I was I
mean I have an RI of an argument pairs
is that it's not normal it's right and
I'd be like what your definition of
normal is different to mine because you
just grew up in a different world
well let's look at you know one of you
another piece of your music and this is
kill somebody
[Music]
you
[Music]
somebody kill somebody
[Music]
but it
[Music]
and as we were watching that there I
mean you you were saying to me they said
this is one of those songs that really
resonates with your families why do you
think it's so direct you know I think
for me that was a part in my life like
everyone's like oh do you want to kill
I'm like it's me looking in the mirror
thinking about suicide like and
depression and an anxiety in feeling
that I'm not good enough and feeling
that that I'm I'm not quite right for
this world I know it's hard I know that
sounds really weird to hear to people
who don't understand it but I think if
you've ever been at that place and you
will understand it you know it's kind of
it's so bizarre to be like I'm sad and
people like why and you like I don't
know and that's what people can't fathom
they get kind of they get kind of angry
when you I I don't know it's like what
come on if you must know and I'm like I
genuinely just don't I just can't
explain it and just I just feel like
I've been it in the stomach seven times
and I don't know why why do you feel so
comfortable talking about these these
big social political issues may be
psychotic kids we've mentioned you know
I love you will you marry me you know
there are two people caught between
different sorts from different
socioeconomic backgrounds you know
machine-gun brackets the NRA I mean
that's pretty self-explanatory but it's
a boat for you yeah that's what it's
about for me it's about me saying what I
think and me going I think this is
what's wrong with the world and I think
this is what what I genuinely feel why
would I write music or censor myself if
I didn't feel it you know I mean I'm
just all these songs and all these
subjects I just want to talk about and
when I take them is about management
sometimes like Waldheim you've gone
pretty pretty far but what's been
amazing is my label and management I've
just supported me because I need to talk
about this I'm not gonna censor this
well you changed a couple lyrics here
and there no I don't want to fine okay
we trust you and I'm like thank you
because it's so easy to do that isn't it
you change a couple roots to conform so
you know I mean it can be it's not gonna
it's gonna dilute it a little bit so
more people will be able to feel it
this generation ain't ain't thinking
that you have a view of bricks I mean
yeah a hundred percent man got it now
I think as I say like I was so
disappointed man I remember waking up
that morning and like my heart went in
my stomach because that was the first
time I got to vote mm-hmm you know I was
18 and it was the first time like I
actually genuinely got to have my say
and you and you felt like that was
something that you wanted to do I mean
yeah musicians of the press that's what
I'm saying as I say my version of punk
it is not necessarily like I'm an the
system is it's it's let's let's work
together to create conversation to
obtain about a world that's my version
of punk because that's just what it is
that's what I think and it's and I
wanted to remain man I think and it's
and it's crazy when we think about young
people actually broke records with that
record it was with that election it was
it was it was like Trump in the u.s.
when young people turned out and it was
totally robbed by an older generation
and what annoyed me and upset me man it
was it was a lot of it was built on a
foundation of Lies as well man when you
talk about like you do these points that
are gonna prey on people that just see
the surface and go are 350 million is
gonna go into the NHS and then the wake
up on breakfast TV two hours after the
decisions been made so oh well actually
that's not happening it's like what it's
like and an older generation robbed us
of that you know I mean because all
we've been there before we think it's
better it's going to make us it's gonna
make us a more sovereign nation it's
like well no it's not actually it's
gonna it's gonna it's gonna take away
our influence on one of the largest
continents of the world it really deeply
hurt me when I was when my country that
I love so much is alone so yeah I mean
given the fact that the people who voted
for that other people who are going to
die before you exactly exactly
but do you hate them do you hate all the
older generation for having inflicted
this upon you I mean I don't hate
anybody
because you know I mean but I'm
disappointed and I'm sad that you didn't
listen to us and you didn't think we're
not gonna be here what did they want
what did they want to do what what you
know I mean like what what I didn't I
that we didn't even take that into
account
mm-hm for me it was like we're gonna be
found but I'm gonna be totally dead and
buried before I know it sounds so harsh
but I'm gonna be told we're dead and
gone before this even makes a difference
what do they want to do what's the
consensus of young people because
because they're gonna be our age by the
time these things are inflicted you know
do you ever leave open the possibility
that you know fast forward 30 40 years
your views might have changed at that
point so be honest man I always as I say
I all just want to be like I was out
fully like touch wood and this is on
telly so you can tape this and whatever
hopefully I'm not some 70 year old man
and Def Leppard t-shirt screaming about
how things could have been you know but
I just say I always want to be
open-minded I will always be open-minded
I think I will always listen to the way
things go and as I say if I ever end up
being like oh it's not normal man back
in my day shoot me so much there's so
much in your music that it there is at
least expressing a frustration if not an
anger yeah about things it's it almost
at times feels like you're you're kind
of not calling for for a revolution you
know that we have France introduced ago
but you know but a revolution of sorts
and at the same time yours is you know
commonly referred to by you know older
people the ones are going to die before
you as the snowflake generation yeah I
just want enough of us to unite because
a lot of people want to talk a lot of
people are angry so how hopeful are you
that your generation can't can change
things because you know when you were
mentioning your influences before there
are people like yourself who said these
things in some of these things before
and we are where we are I agree man and
but I think man I think it's a different
time now because if you think about man
if you think about in the days there
like Joe Strummer in a clash man
everything was so in your country in
your country in your country it's so
international now I can talk to someone
in Singapore in Nijmegen in Holland in
Bonner Springs Texas on to what Twitter
and it's just said
International World young people ain't
bothered about just young people in
Britain now it's a kind of a global
thing you know I mean if I got someone
in Australia or whatever we're all
thinking of saying you know I mean we're
all genuinely thinking the same things
and it's like that's what's so inspiring
and gives me out man because as I say we
are gonna we are the people below us as
well you just got a look at Emma
Gonzales and you like people like that
in the u.s. activist young activists
like that we have a platform to talk now
before we could act we could get in I
don't know we'd we'd we'd start a riot
in bloody Westminster and it'd get
printed maybe an on a on a newspaper
that would be censored by a
editor-in-chief that's working alongside
the government but now I can post
something on the internet that can't be
censored that cannot be that cannot be
that cannot be kind of suppressed this
it's it's it's it's an outlet for
anybody to have a platform and that's
amazing man Michael in in hicktown
America can can have his view and can
can say that I want to be who I want to
be and that's just amazing to me man you
know I mean so what do you think what do
you make then of those who see that the
wisdom the merit and borders you know
people who disagree with you let's take
one example
Tommy Robinson what do you make of him
people people I say with me I want
backlash I won outraged and one someone
asked me that was like you say everyone
should up be able to have their opinion
so what about the neo-nazis someone said
that to me in an interview and I said I
want everyone to have their opinion
because if there weren't then we can't
fight against them there's not
conversation and it cannot be seen
there's no definition between wrong or
right because everyone just partners
along in this world with no conversation
I want backlash I don't want peace but
do you do you meet Tommy Robinson we
need people like that and now it sounds
that's that's a very controversial thing
but we need people like that so we can
fight against it and we can be heard
if there's not that then there's nothing
there's no conversation if that I get
it's not a bloody broken record there is
no conversation we're just like I don't
know mom would just we may as well just
be like fruit in a fruit basket to sit
in their lap man so I mean please don't
dream the interview yeah no no I just I
see your particular points but about the
conversation I take your points about
you what you want to remain a saint it
but do you think do you ever sit by the
fire at night with a cup of cocoa and
think what am I going to be in 10 years
time are we ever gonna see you know
young blood the Christmas the the
Christmas album for example they can't
you see yourself ever sailing oh and I
don't know I think to be honest like
what is what is the definition of
selling out man I want to just do what's
true of me and as I say in 10 years man
I'm I'm gonna I might see the world
differently you know I mean I might do
and yeah man I'm just gonna write what
I'm gonna write but I'm just gonna be
truthful to you I'm never gonna lie to
you you know I mean I'm never gonna you
know I mean if I lie people seem is
selling out if I want to write a love
song yeah I mean nobody like why is he
written a love song you don't do that
it's like they're you not understanding
me as an artist I'm although I'm never
gonna be as truthful to you all I'm ever
gonna do is talk about what's going on
in my head all I'm ever gonna do is you
know I mean if I want to do a song with
a populist artist in the world but it's
real then it's what I'm gonna do you
know I mean because that's just the
person I am and the artist I am and I
think it's kind of crazy I always get a
bit nervous when I'm kind of seen in the
studio with some more commercial artists
because people go like I'm always
worried if people got a selling out but
the response is always crazy because I
genuinely believe like people people
believe me that I'm gonna watch be
truthful because I genuinely am you know
I mean I'm always just gonna do what I
do and not give it you know I mean
that's just what I am gonna do because I
think that's in my nature I think
Dominic Dom mr. blood makes a little
Lords of it mr. mr. blood Thanks thank
you so much man that was sick